hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today we're hopping back on
Monster Hunter again and today we're
gonna be talking about how to find all
the three elder dragon tracks and how to
do it the fastest after you defeat
gnorga ghonte you're gonna be getting a
quest that there's these random tracks
appearing everywhere according to the
quest
apparently nurger ghonte obviously him
being the feasting on elder dragons a
lot of the elder dragons were scared and
ran off and are not walking into the
different areas in the new world and
specifically wildfire waste Rotten Vale
in the ancient forests so your job is to
track these monsters down by finding the
tracks finding these tracks though can
be a little bit tricky since they are
hidden and there's only a few tracks
that appear at a time so we're gonna go
over where to find these tracks the
fastest so let's get started so the
first place we're gonna go to is the
ancient forest so you want to spawn at
the first camp and then head forward
until you find this ledge and the gashes
should appear there if they don't appear
don't worry
we will get to that but once you collect
the gashes you want to keep moving
forward until you reach the ledge
overlooking the ocean and then there
should be some more gashes right there
once you grab those returned back to
base and then go back to the HM forest
to reset the tracks and repeat the
process like I said earlier they don't
always spawn there so if they don't
appear head back and follow this path
instead of going forward to the ledge
like we did previously and go a little
to the left near the pond and there
should be a set of two footprints sadly
these are the only two I could find
within the general area so after that go
back to base travel back to the ancient
forest once again to reset the tracks
rinse and repeat until you're finished
next up is wild spire waste this one at
rotten Ville are going to have a
straight shot track so there's none of
these guessing which one is which
there's gonna be a little bit easier you
want to spawn on the middle camp crawl
through the hole that's there turned
slightly to the left and instead of
going right where there's that big gap
where you have to jump in go left up the
slope and then if you continue forward
you should see a set of two footprints
that will be near and under or under the
archway
if you then turn right a little bit and
then continue forward there should be a
set of footprints on the ground
if this gets a little bit too confusing
just follow the video instead of my
voice it's a lot easier to look at that
than how I'm kind of explaining it
because it's very hard to explain when
all of it is just a bunch of rocks in
this area and then lastly continuing
forward if you slide down the sand right
there there should be a hill on your
left and then there should be some fur
you can take and then like I always say
return to the base reset the tracks go
back to the wild spire waste rinse and
repeat and then you should have both of
those areas done lastly we have the
rotten veil this one's probably the
longest path out of all of them but it's
probably the most useful at the moment
so to start you want to go to the
southeast camp on the second floor from
there jump down head to the left
and there should be some footprints
continuing downwards you should go
through the whole toxic area where you
would normally meet the great garros
until you continue and there's
absolutely no toxic area left at the end
there should be some footprints there
and then you want to continue following
the path until you reach the blue
electric sea water there should be
either some flesh or footprints there as
well right by the entrance
afterwards you want to continue forward
and you should get two or three more
footprints until you reach the end and
you already know the drill or turn to
the base reload the rotten veil for the
footprints to reset follow the same path
until you have enough opens to complete
the quest since we now have all three
areas done you want to go back to the
base once you have everything done go
back to astera talk to the Huntsman the
field team leader and then go to the
research base and talk to the third
fleet leader to receive the quest to
hunt these three dragons that you were
tracking down you could choose to accept
them at once or one at a time we're all
once it doesn't really matter it is up
to your choosing and that's it hopefully
you guys enjoyed that it is currently
wednesday when i'm recording this and
should this should be off hopefully
uploaded on friday as of right now all
the dragons the throughout of the three
dragons that we get from this quest i
have slain two of them there is still
one more he is the one that you get from
the wild spire way so I'm going to
probably go beat him so expect some
guides on these characters these guys
are a little bit tough but there is they
are pretty easy to understand once you
get the hang of it like I said guys that
is going to be the end of the video if
you guys did enjoy be sure to give it a
like it really does help me out so
subscribe if you're new I post tons of
Monster Hunter World content I'm
starting to get into this game a lot
more I have tons of hours plugged down
this game I'm gonna be doing guides for
all the monsters eventually when I start
to slay them I'm gonna be doing news and
petulance updates if they ever come out
with those in the future and other stuff
like that regarding this game lots of
guides l2 tips lots of news I'm gonna
start covering majority of that for all
of you guys most of you guys seem to be
enjoying that so I'm going to continue
to do that
but two most recent videos are gonna be
on screen if you guys didn't miss those
and want to check them up they're there
for that
subscriber free new like I said and with
that guys hope you have a great rest of
your day and peace out